bienvenidos a mi presentación del nivel
3 de las ecuaciones nivel 3 y del nivel
3 de las ecuaciones lineales en esta
ocasión vamos a poner la siguiente
ecuación no voy a quedar con x + 2x ya
esto le voy a sumar 3 x + 2 x + 3 es
igual a 7 no no mejor menos 7 x menos 5
7 x menos 5 la idea que hay detrás de
estas ecuaciones lineales es simplificar
todo lo que tenga que ver con la
variable x y todo lo que tenga que ver
con los números para que así nos quede
una ecuación del nivel 1 que habíamos
visto hace dos presentaciones recuerda
que lo que queremos es despejar a equis
y encontrar el valor de x que satisfaga
esta ecuación así que lo primero que voy
a hacer es fijarme en este lado
izquierda de la ecuación y voy a
simplificar x 2 x es como si tuviera una
manzana más dos manzanas pues son tres
manzanas es decir x más 12 x son 3 x + 3
esto es igual a menos 7 x
-5 ahora bien a continuación lo que voy
a hacer es pasar todo lo que tiene que
ver con la variable x del lado izquierdo
de la ecuación por lo tanto para quitar
este menos 7x que tengo aquí voy a sumar
7x de ambos lados de la ecuación de tal
manera que menos 7 x + 7 x se cancelan
recuerda que a sumar menos 7 x + 7 x me
daría 0 y 0 menos 5 el mismo que menos 5
por lo tanto estos dos se van y del lado
derecho que me quedan 7 x + 3 x es 10 x
10 x + 3 es igual a menos 5 y date
cuenta ya pusimos a todas las x de un
lado de la ecuación del lado izquierdo
eso es un primer gran paso ahora lo que
quiero que veas es que ahora tenemos una
ecuación del tipo 2 del nivel 2 y por lo
tanto debe hacer es restar menos 3 de
ambos lados de la ecuación para que se
cancele este 3 y yo lo pueda pasar del
otro lado de la ecuación y me quede 10 x
igual a menos 5 menos 3 que es menos 8 y
así obtendrá una ecuación del nivel 1
del primer vídeo que vimos y por lo
tanto lo que voy a hacer es dividir
entre 10 para cancelar este 10 que está
al lado de la equis o en todo caso
multiplicar
undécimo y recuerda que lo que estoy
haciendo es multiplicando por el inverso
multiplicativo de 10 para que así un
décimo por 10 se cancele me quede 1 y
entonces ya pueda tener a la equis
despejada del lado izquierdo de la
ecuación y entonces ahí va un décimo por
10 x es lo mismo que x mientras que el
otro lado me queda menos 8 sobre 10 y si
te das cuenta menos 8 sobre 10 lo
podemos simplificar un poco esto es lo
mismo que menos cuatro quintos menos
cuatro sobre cinco y perfecto ya con
esto obtuve el valor de x el valor de x
que solucione esta ecuación que tengo
aquí arriba es igual a menos cuatro
quintos así que vamos a intentar hacer
otro ejemplo en donde haya bastantes
variables x de ambos lados de la
ecuación y además bastantes constantes
así que vamos a poner 5 x menos tres
menos 7 x esto voy a decir que es igual
a se me ocurre a x más 8 muy bien ahora
es muy buen momento para que tú padres
el vídeo e intentas hacerlo por ti mismo
vayas jugando con estos números y con
esta ecuación a ver si llegas
y así sirve de paso que haces tus
propios experimentos así que voy a
asumir que ya para este vídeo porque
justo ahorita voy a empezar a resolver
esta ecuación porque tengo 5 x 7 x estos
dos puede reducir de igual manera que en
el ejercicio pasado por lo tanto si
tengo 5 x 7 x es como si tuviera cinco
manzanas menos siete manzanas pues
entonces debo dos manzanas es decir 5 x
menos 7 x es menos 2 x menos 2 x menos 3
es igual a x más 8 y date cuenta que
este menos 3 no puedo operarlo con las x
porque no tiene x y bueno a continuación
voy a quitar esta x de lado derecho de
igual manera que hice en el ejercicio
pasado restando x de ambos lados de la
ecuación así del lado izquierdo me
quedan menos x menos 12 x lo cual es
menos 3 x menos 3 x menos 3 y del lado
derecho x - x se van que es justo lo que
yo quería y solamente me queda hoy
después voy a quitar este menos 3 este
menos 3 lo voy a quitar sumando 3 de
ambos lados de la ecuación estos 3 se
van y me queda simple y sencillamente
menos 3x y del lado derecho me queda 11
- 3 x 11 y por lo tanto para acabar este
ejercicio voy a multiplicar por el
inverso multiplicativo de menos 3 el
cual es menos un tercio de ambos lados
de la ecuación y menos un tercio por
menos 3 se van y solamente me queda x
mientras que del lado derecho me queda
menos 11 tercios y bueno ya tengo la
solución de esta ecuación y de hecho
creo que sería bastante bueno
intentaremos hacer la comprobación de
esta ecuación así que vamos a hacerlo
tengo 5 veces x 5 x menos 11 tercios
pues cuántos 5 x menos 11 tercios
recuerda que lo que estoy haciendo
sustituyendo el valor de x en esta
ecuación cada vez que yo vea una x voy a
poner menos 11 tercios 5 x menos 11
tercios al menos 55 tercios y después a
esto hay que quitarle menos 3 pero al
menos 3 lo voy a ver en tercios una vez
para que todo me quede en tercios y
pueda significar en el siguiente paso
entonces el 9 poner menos 3 voy a poner
menos 9 tercios todos lo estoy
escribiendo con un denominador común y
después me queda menos 7 por equis pero
x vale menos 11 tercios entonces va a
quedar menos x menos más
7 x 11 77 77 muy bien este salió de
menos 11 tercios por menos 7 y del otro
lado me queda x pero x vale menos 11
tercios y después de que sumarle 8 pero
recuerda que el 8 lo voy a ver también
en tercios para que todo quede en
tercios 8 es lo mismo que 24 tercios muy
bien así que vamos a hacer las
operaciones de un lado de la ecuación y
del otro lado de la ecuación para ver si
llegamos a una igualdad menos 55 menos 9
es menos 64 menos 64 tercios más 77
tercios según mis cuentas son 13 tercios
es decir de todo esto son 13 tercios
dejan operando aquí 13 tercios del lado
izquierdo vamos a ver si llego a lo
mismo del lado derecho
- 11 tercios más 24 tercios esto me da
13 tercios también perfecto por lo tanto
la comprobación ya está lista acabo de
llegar a una igualdad tanto del lado
derecho como del lado izquierdo y lo
mismo y por lo tanto el valor de x igual
a menos 11 tercios hace que se cumpla
esta adecuación y aquí ya tienes el
nivel 3 el cuadro un poco más
el nivel 2 pero lo que tienes que hacer
es reducir las variables de nuevo de la
ecuación reducir las constantes del otro
lado de la ecuación y te va a quedar una
ecuación del nivel 1